I'll go into this video playing
one-trick pony i recently lost against
the sky I mean recently means I'm in the
session even with a kind of help mate so
let's see what what happened cm and now
the other game I think we had had the
chi going where you played some position
positionally very suspect moves but it
didn't matter we go son while I was
running into the cell mate as mentioned
key we transposed into something that
quite often can arise out of the the
news oh this typical isolated pawn
position the only nights is six is a bit
as a bit uncommon
yeah okay quite strange but well after
the first game I I know what to expect
some some weird moves now is always in
the spin this is quite quite annoying
from for black usually you just return
here or you have a position where you
have a night on d7 so that you can play
Queen c7 comfortably but yeah it's not
clear how we ever gets rid of the pin I
mean g5 is just insane okay so this is
the the way he's trying to get out of
the pen okay let's let's take dumb yeah
well how to how to proceed now queen 22
to f4 s 1 id m I'll be sure before but I
really don't want to exchange material
the bishop also controls at five and g6
some limits the noid okay let's go here
Bishop f3 I take h6 intermediate muth
threatening the meydan h7 so he needs to
react first yeah but the move like that
and now I thought Queen f4 Queen f/4g
for h5 the scanned of route you know
okay I mean the some look strange a bit
for black but it seems so it seems still
so playable especially if you manage to
get rid of more pieces let's say it
takes on f3 and place 936 this is not it
doesn't do that that's not brilliant but
playable
okay oops night the night is not badly
placed on e5 for sure
of course my rookie 3g 3m now as a
threat it probably needs to react hmm
yes one of the possible reactions
yeah f3 is not a move I want to play
how to proceed maybe see 45 m this is a
good idea really if i manage c4 and d5
this would be would be nice and there's
always rookie 3 2 g-3 let's let's be
bothered
again this this
mer okay that's taken
it's a weak weak porn on only six or you
have our King teens looks insane ok well
now yellow g5 I should probably make
sure that g5 is not so easily playable
yeah I don't want to exchange greens
that's that's that much is clear c-45
break open the position with d5 t5 takes
rook e1 intending lucky 7 yeah come on
this must be right if this is not right
then not much I can do about it rookie 7
the idea and I've got h5 breaking up the
whole the whole position
mmm I didn't see that move at all
Wow lookie seven
you can take with the Queen
unfortunately
Yahoo p8 was a good defensive means
okay well we'll have this fret and a
half h5 young come on page five
trying to
to bust up his Kings position
this Bishop is also ready to join on d3
only slightly reduced material can be a
check can be a problem look at Queen f4
Queen III not sure but this looks good
having a 5 is under heavy pressure now
check
hmm
c5 and Bishop c4 yo Bishop d3 would be
nice but it's medium
Luke f6 this Queen g5
it's still remarkably resilient this
position at least I don't see anything
which is probably due to well it's it's
probably just my problem I just don't
see the right right continuation
d3 is so serious counterplay
hmm what about f3 and Bishop d3 you can
play d3 though but take a look take soca
fete snow in remarkably I don't see a
move what the heck unbelievable that's
probably just good for white but I don't
see it now Queen g5 what what else check
yeah this is not not great at all I
didn't see something I didn't see
anything great at least he's taking some
time check time warning
check I just watch the heck haha I just
I just thought I can take the porn
unbelievable it's a genesis kind of help
make game lie just like the first one
where he's playing bad mucho and over
and I'm running into a helpmate
basically check yeah will resign quite
resigned yeah well I'm just an idiot
what can you say I just forgot that this
is this is protected but I that I what
the heck there must be something in this
position his King is wide open yeah c5
is the winner yeah but i didn't i were i
was simply failing to see a move here
quincy for is winning check check
yo hmm
yeah that's not easy not easy at all
check
yeah woke you need to see all this kind
of stuff you need to see check even hear
it looks slightly tricky but if I have
oops nope I have had this move
yeah and after that time in China each
other had a good end game here Chang I
don't know what was what I was thinking
when I took when I took their check I
really forgot that he is protected it
just the otic i can i can just play any
move and i'm just a born up for not for
not much and while the whole position
was so they're not winning this is
heartbreaking i mean this is just just
so bad
Bishop d3 is also better whatever they
what I played is plus 3 taking on frm
it's just a just batten check this is
not not not bad but check it's just not
the the best possible way to play I was
also thinking about this move but I
wasn't sure if I can take him I didn't
see a win here but there's Queen Jayde
winning oh man oh man I needed to play
like 10 completely idiotic moves to lose
the game but I managed thanks for
watching